a habit is a redundant set of automatic
unconscious thoughts behaviors and
emotions that's acquired through
repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind
so now the person running through the
same routine every single day is on
autopilot and their body's now dragging
them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists
is the sweet spot of the generous
present moment that is when the body and
mind are free from those conditions so
along with those emotions that influence
the same thoughts
people start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled they start
getting more afraid more anxious more
depressed and now the body is literally
being depleted
of energy because it's believing that
it's living in an emergency situation
and in emergency you tap all the body's
resources for some threat whether it's
real or imagined
and so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool
but the arousal that's created from
those stress hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems
and the conditions in their life to
reaffirm their conditioning or their
addiction to that emotion and in a sense
they become addicted to the life they
don't even like and this is why change
is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay i'm not
going to say i can't i'm not going to
judge another person i'm not going to
blame i'm not going to complain i'm not
going to make excuses i'm not going to
be a victim i'm not going to talk trash
about anybody i'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours
and the bodies saying you're out of
schedule you normally at eight in the
morning you're getting traffic and
you're angry then at 11 o'clock you
check your emails and you're really
judgmental and frustrated the body's
saying well you've been doing this for
the last 20 years you're just going to
stop today so now the body which has
been conditioned emotionally to be the
mind wants to return back to its
familiar territory to the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on
this is a good time to judge that come
on this is a good time to suffer it's
your ex's fault it's it's your it's the
government's fault it's uh
you know it's the weather what the news
whatever it is and if we
accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those pharmacy of
chemicals
and so that's when the person makes the
same choice
does the same thing
creates the same experience just for
that familiar feeling okay i'll complain
just so i can feel suffering then
they'd rather
be unhappy
than step into the unknown
need motivation watch the top 10 with
believe nation top 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best dr joe
dispenza and my take on his top 10 rules
for success enjoy
rule number two change your energy i
think that emotions are energy in motion
and so let's just say that
um we share the same experiences okay i
don't we're friends and we share the
same experience you're from london i've
been to london my daughter lives in
london and we have hey you do this i do
that you did the you know you own this i
own that you know so what we do is we
actually look to see when we meet people
if we're matching neurologically if
we're matching emotionally so if we
share the same experiences we share the
same emotions and if we share the same
emotions we can relate to one another so
this is where it gets sticky so then the
moment you start saying ah
that person did that to you once yeah
that person i had a similar experience
that person did that to me now
now
we open the door like i'm gonna use you
to
reaffirm my
attachment to that emotion
and let's just work it up so that you
can suffer and i can suffer and then we
can have a conversation and literally
we're sharing the same energy and if
we're sharing the same energy we're
sharing the same information and we're
bound by an invisible field
of energy that keeps us connected yes so
then what does it take to break that
energetic field an energy that's greater
than the energy that's holding it
together that's how you separate atoms
that become a molecule you they're
they're bound by an invisible field of
energy that's keeping them connected so
you got to use a greater energy than the
energy that's holding them together to
separate them well in order for you to
change then you can't have energy
without awareness or consciousness
you've got to go to a greater level of
consciousness and change your energy and
nobody changes jay until they change
their energy when they change their
energy they change their life so then
you may say well this person you know i
i use this person and i use my enemy to
reaffirm my addiction to hatred i use my
co-worker to reaffirm my addiction to
judgment i use my ex to reaffirm my
addiction to resentment that we have
these different people in our lives that
we need to remind us of who we think we
are the enemy dies and you find another
one
you know you know your co-worker
leaves and you start judging another one
it's just
it's not any it's not that so then
when there's no longer a vibrational
match
when you start doing the work
there's no longer a vibrational match
with you and your past present reality
that that person or that condition any
longer
that person or condition is going to
spiral away because you're no longer
you're no longer in need of that so then
our life begins to change when we change
our energy and we begin to take our
power back that's essential for us to
begin to create with now some people
can't handle that because
they're not conscious that they're doing
it so they'll be working on their vision
of the future and yet they'll spend two
hours
lowering their energy back into
victimization or suffering and they want
to know why their future isn't happening
well
there's an unconscious program let's go
after that and once you start going
after that
now all of a sudden your life starts to
change again so you can't say it doesn't
work
on some level we don't work and if
you're really invested in this
the question is what is it about me
where am i directing my attention or my
energy who am i using to reaffirm some
conditioning that i need to remember as
my old self so then when you stop
reacting to the person or the person's
now complaining to you and you're not
complaining back
it's going to be an uncomfortable moment
because
you're all of a sudden seeing a part of
you
you used to be that you no longer are
and you have to be willing
to not go there and over time that
person will thank you and they'll say
i didn't even know that i was
complaining that much and
by changing yourself you help others
rule number three match your behavior to
your intentions self-love is no longer
about pleasure or having a car it's
something that you're cultivating within
you so then imagine we have research to
show and this is such a this is such a
duality
that when you start seeing the brain
start synchronizing getting coherent the
front of the brain and the back of the
brain that two hemispheres coming
together and you we can say to
scientists that come and study our work
oh watch this ed's gonna pop what do you
mean just watch this is gonna be good
and all of a sudden you see this brain
going into this kind of psychic union
the heart blows wide open you see
coherence going on and you look around
at that person and there's tears running
down their face
imagine feeling so whole
that it's impossible to want i mean how
can you want when you're whole because
you feel like you already have it now
when you reach that point
that's when the magic happens because
now you are worthy to receive and the
universe only gives us what we think
we're worthy of receiving share this
with them please yeah i think you know
for me i mean
um
i'm curious and i'm a pragmatist i mean
if you tell me something all i want to
know is how i'm going to use it in my
life yes and i'm not in the dinner
conversation because nobody changes from
that you know i i mean i'm a doer and i
want to be around doers and
that's why you and i connect so well i
think and i yeah yeah obviously and and
and and uh
you you create a group of people that
are passionate about transformation and
they've they've done some of the work
when we were doing our four day four and
a half day uh advanced workshops right
around the end of the event i was seeing
people starting to notice seeing some
really great transformations and i
thought this is the pop yeah it's a pop
yeah big pops yeah and we were like we
had to send them home
and i was like oh god man if i could
just have them for a week so we created
these week-long events where people
retreat from their lives
and
they remove the constant stimulation in
their external environment that reminds
them of who they think they are as a
personality yes they separate themselves
from the people they know and the places
they go and the things that they do at a
certain amount of time in their routine
mundane life so we'll bridge a little
quantum physics with a little neural
science little neuro uh endocrinology a
little epigenetics uh
psychoneuroimmunology those are all
sciences about possibility and i now
know that if you can give people sound
scientific information and you know
for me that's the language
and then if they can turn to the person
next to them and explain it you're not
going to get off the hook
if you can't explain it it's not wired
in your brain but if you can build a
model and explain it you're installing
the neurological hardware in your brain
in preparation for the experience so the
more you understand what you're doing
and why
how it gets easier because you can
assign meaning to it so then if i can
set up the conditions in the environment
and give them the proper instructions
and push the envelope a little bit yeah
and people who get their behaviors to
match their intentions and their actions
equal to their thoughts they get their
mind and body working together
they're gonna have a new experience and
the experience then is not only to
enrich the philosophical circuits in the
brain because experience does that but
it's going to produce an emotion so
they're going to start feeling more
unlimited rule number four overcome your
old personality you ought to stay
conscious
and not go unconscious and it turns out
that 95 of the time we're unconscious so
if you're going to stay conscious then
there's an element that also requires a
certain amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so the thoughts that
they're thinking
are slipping by their awareness
unnoticed because they're hardwired in
their brain because they've been saying
i can't it's too hard my life will never
change it's someone else's fault those
thoughts have consequences in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious
of those unconscious thoughts becomes
aware of how they speak and how they act
and they notice
how they're feeling they're no longer
the program they're the consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
there are
when you when you're distracted by your
environment and you got your cell phone
and your tweeting and your
instagramming and facebook and whatever
people do you're distracted by that
feeling
but i now know that if you take a person
and you say okay close your eyes
sit in the in the silence of any
external stimulation remove the
environment sit your body down like an
animal body is the animal tell it to
stay i'm going to feed you
you can check your cell phone you can
shower you can have your coffee but when
i say
and so then here comes the challenge
right so and and then
if you say then you're not going to live
in the familiar future familiar past or
predictable future you're not going to
think about how long you've been
meditating what you got to do you you
labor
uh for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it
but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say i
think i'm meditating wrong i always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and
check your cell phone or have a cup of
coffee and you become aware that it's on
autopilot and wants to do that and you
say
come on over here
and you return it back to the present
moment
you're executing a will now
that's greater than the program and if
the person
wants to just get angry while they're
sitting there there's an arousal and
they notice the body is amping up and
revving up and they settle it back down
now they're telling the body it's no
longer the mind
that they're the mind now we've
researched this
and it's tedious
in the beginning at first because david
is fighting goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner or later the body is trained to a
new mind and when that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from the body as
energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life
and they're
they're working and lowering the volume
that emotion the more they lower the
volume of that emotion the more they're
going to take their attention off that
person and problem and they're going to
take their power back there's going to
be a break
in their attention from that
circumstance and now they build their
own field and now there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because they've overcome their
old personality self so
i think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming
overcoming
overcoming overcoming until we become
somebody else and when that occurs and
the person starts thinking differently
and they start acting differently
and they start feeling differently
they're a new personality and
they they start seeing those
synchronicities and serendipities also
if you want to have more self-confidence
and self-belief the sign says it can
take up to
254 days of consecutive action for the
habit to stick that's what i want for
you so i've designed a custom free
program where i'm going to send you an
unlisted video for the next 254 days to
shift your confidence and belief forward
the link to join is in the description
below you were up and dressed and ready
to go before your parents were up you
know why because you knew something
unexpected was going to happen that's
how we should live our lives waking up
with the understanding to expect the
unexpected if you're going to speak
effectively
you have to know way more than you're
talking about today
what creates marketing is when you don't
just market but you add value to people
rule number five elevate yourself
how
bad does it have to get i mean to what
denominator
to what lowest level do you have to
reach
before people really make up their mind
to change my message is why wait i mean
when you're feeling so altered
emotionally you feel so bad that's the
moment you could actually see yourself
for the first time because you're you're
not answering your cell phone you're not
responding to all your texts you're not
watching tv you're not going out to
dinners you're not calling people back
you're something's altered in you and
you're starting to become self-aware
right
so then
people wait to that lowest moment where
they can start to see themselves through
the eyes of somebody else well
if you're waking up every day and you're
combining a clear intention with an
elevated emotion and you're changing
your emotional state to be elevated
you could still see the old self from an
elevated point of view and be state
conscious then from a limited point of
view and that's what i want for people
like let's go i mean what do you got to
lose what people are going to start
wondering like did you change your
medication what's up with that guy
something's different about him you're
not predictable any longer right then we
say to our our community you know when
you're changing you just stop talking
about it you're just too busy being it
something's happening you know and
that's
the repetition of getting a few days in
a row
of that really well i always say god if
you had a great meditation you wake up
feeling better
at the end of that meditation than when
you started
and you do that the next day and then
the next day you're gonna start feeling
better all the time and that your body's
gonna start feeling better and
everything's gonna start feeling better
and you're gonna start feeling better
about life rule number six be passionate
about your future so
you ask the person why are you so
unhappy why are you so frustrated why
are you so resentful the moment you ask
that their brain is going to associate
that emotion to a past event to a memory
to a memory
that's because they have nothing to look
forward to in their future so if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it just means to me that you're
more in love with your past
than you are with a future so how do you
teach people to believe in a future that
they can't see or experience with their
senses yet
but they've thought about enough times
in their mind that their brain is
literally changed to look like the event
has already occurred the latest research
in neuroscience says that's absolutely
possible we know that and how do you
teach a person
to select a new possibility in their
future and begin to emotionally embrace
that future before it's made manifest to
such a degree that their body as their
unconscious mind is believing it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and they're signaling new
genes in new ways ahead of the
environment
now to their body begins to change to
look like the event has already occurred
we've proven that that's possible now
think about this so the more you think
about your desired future the joy
the gratitude the
uh the feelings you want to have that
are more positive the more you think
about it as it's as a future thing
happening the more your body shifts now
exactly so your body is believing it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment now think about this the
stronger the emotion you feel from some
condition in your life the more altered
you feel inside of you the more you
narrow your focus on the cause and the
brain freezes an image and takes a
snapshot and that memory now is embossed
in the brain it's branded in there so
then people think neurologically within
the circuits of those past experiences
and they feel chemically within the
boundaries of those emotions and the
stronger the betrayal the stronger the
trauma
the more the body's living in the past
right so then so how to reverse that so
now
if you truly got passionate about a
future we've all done this you get a
wild idea in your mind and you start
holding on to that vision and you're
preoccupied with it all of a sudden the
thought in your mind becomes the
experience and you start feeling the the
energy of the future now the stronger
the emotion you feel from that vision
the more you're going to pay attention
to the picture in your mind and now
you're remembering your future and vice
versa the stronger you pay attention to
the feeling of the past pain you're
going to create the pain in this moment
exactly so then so it requires a
coherent brain
and we now know that there's a formula
for that and we've got beautiful
research to show that people can do it
they just have to practice and it
requires a coherent heart because
resentment frustration in patience
creates a very incoherent heart yeah and
when that heart becomes incoherent you
stop trusting yourself there's no energy
you stop trusting in your future
so then if there's physical evidence in
your brain and body
physical evidence to look like the event
has already occurred
it's quite possible you'll be thinking
neurologically within the circuits of
your future and you begin to feel
chemically within the boundaries of that
emotion of your future and how you think
and how you feel is your state of being
and now your state of being is living in
the future instead of the past now
the moment you disconnect from the
emotion of your future because traffic
or some co-worker or your ex or whatever
people come up with
now you're back to the energy of your
past and now you're going to start
looking for it analyzing why hasn't it
happened well if you're feeling the
emotion of your future why would you
look for it because you would feel like
it already happened and that is the
place where the magic happens so then
you can't just do this
get up and then return back to your old
state of being you got to maintain that
modified statement
when life happens small let me finish
with a face right now how do you
maintain well of course of course i mean
we all take blows in our lives and we
all react emotionally but the question
is
how long are you going to reach right
right so then if you can't mediate and
regulate your emotional reactions and
those emotions linger for days that's
years for some people mood and then
months temperament
years personality trait so then the
person's personality is literally based
on the past but they don't know that
because they're doing it over and over
again it becomes a subconscious program
so now
if it requires a coherent brain and a
coherent heart then we have to train
people how to self-regulate rule number
seven program your mind what thoughts do
you want to fire in wire in your brain
what kind of
attention and intention
do you want to place so that that
becomes the loudest voice in your head
and if you keep practicing it the
hardware becomes a software program and
it'll say jay you can do anything jay
you live in no time and accomplish
everything jay
you're unlimited you just got to hang
with it on the other side of this is
greatness whatever you want to program
in there you get the program in there if
you sat down and say how am i going to
be with my wife my husband my partner
how am i going to be with my kids i'm
going to be at work with my co-workers
how am i going to be in traffic
and you close your eyes and you begin to
rehearse in your mind if you're truly
present the brain does not know the
difference between the real life
experience and what you're imagining
so now the brain goes from a record of
the past to a map to the future now
you're installing the hardware keep
practicing it it becomes automatic comes
easier now it's a software program you
may just start behaving differently rule
number eight refine your intention in
order for you to to really begin to
explore the unknown aspect of yourself
you got to learn how to get beyond the
known aspect of yourself and if you keep
coming back to the known you're going to
miss out on the unknown so you would say
well i don't know anything in the
unknown of course it's the unknown and
if you try to control it there you're
back to the known if you try to predict
it you're back to the known so you got
to go through this trial and error of
just kind of refining your attention
refining your ability and and it's just
got to be something like playing tennis
or playing golf or doing martial arts or
working out or crocheting or stance in
the salsa you just got to keep going man
in the beginning it's tedious and then
when you start finding your groove like
our our community
they don't miss their morning
meditations yeah you know why because
the magic is happening and they know if
they miss it they're gonna they're gonna
cut off from the magic so they whether
they're tired whether they're hungover
whether they're what they're right
they're in right you know and if you if
you wake up in the morning
and you can't get your butt out of bed
you know what that means it just means
you can predict the feeling of
everything that's going to happen in
your life your body's resigned
so then so then you know when you went
on a school trip when you were a kid you
know you woke up before your parents
yeah you knew something new is going to
happen that's the body going wake up
wake up it's something unexpected it's
going to happen what happened to us
christmas day
so why not
you know put in your put in your time
and then and then measure the effects of
you would cause i mean become a
scientist in your life and really start
to experiment with it okay let me change
my energy let me just write down four
thoughts
that like i can it's too hard i'll start
tomorrow this doesn't feel right
whatever it is it's be this person's
fault just write those down and say
these thoughts like gandalf on the
bridge yes you may not pass today this
is the end yes so then if you become
conscious of those thoughts now you're
the governor of your thoughts what what
what actions what behaviors do you want
to change do you complain you blame you
judge do you make excuses how do you
talk do you speak limited just pick four
things
that you're not going to do any longer
yeah
what emotions get you in trouble what
are the emotions that you're addicted to
too right that you're addicted to that
keep you returning back to your past and
if you don't know
close your eyes for about 30 minutes and
just watch where your mind goes and
watch your feelings and just say okay
it's frustration it's unworthiness it's
self-doubt it's guilt it's frustration
it's shame
just
become conscious of those and just
review them in your mind so that you
don't go unconscious them in your waking
day rule number nine decide who you want
to be we have a thousand reasons i have
more than a thousand reasons every day
to be unhappy with managing companies
and staff and people all that but but
then when you rise above that
and you choose just who you want to be
uh i think it makes a big impression
uh on your on your family first yourself
and your family and your friends and the
people you work with and then finally
our communities so i think that people
are starting to figure that out there
and and when they
imagine oxytocin levels in our student
body
the love hormone the love chemical 200
times outside of normal
the latest research on oxytocin a slight
slight elevation on oxytocin it's
impossible to hold a grudge now so then
what that means is you feel
so amazing
that why would you want to
hold a grudge against that person so
forgiveness then is not something that
you have to try to do to be spiritual
it's the side effect of saying
i don't want to give up this feeling for
you or anybody so i'm letting it go i'm
freeing you i'm free in myself and my
goodness there's more liberation of
energy i call that the natural state of
being and we're knocking on that door
why
because as you begin to open your heart
to life again and you start trusting in
your future and trusting in yourself a
little bit more and you start
self-regulating with your heart you do
that properly and you lead from that
place from that level of awareness your
life will change
in dramatic ways and why is that
essential because when people start
doing that effectively
oxytocin signals nitric oxide nitric
oxide signals a chemical called
endothelial derived relaxing factor and
that causes the arteries in your heart
and lungs jay to literally swell just
like when you're
when your sexual organs are aroused and
blood flow moves into them male and
female that's a different consciousness
there's a different energy in there
imagine the same intensity moving into
your heart
that's what people are experiencing that
is a level of love
that's not like a love for your puppy
it's not like the love for your partner
this is transcendent of that this is the
most familiar unfamiliar feeling you
will ever have it'll be distant and at
the same time very close and you'll
start to see the hidden meaning behind
all things and now when you walk in the
presence of your greatest betrayer
the person who threw you under the bus
whatever it is
when you walk in from this place
there will be no emotional reaction you
will just see that person for who they
are who you used to be now compassion
then is no longer something that you
have to try to do
it's the end product of doing the work
and i think that mystics and saints and
masters of old understood this
so when they thought of that person
they didn't allow that thought to
produce a feeling or an energy that
would lower their energy
they understood that when they had the
thought of that person they saw their
limitation it wasn't hurting them it was
only hurting themselves now
i think that if the world was doing that
wow we'd have a very different world and
rule number 10 the last one before some
very special bonus clips is draw your
future to yourself
thoughts uh to me produce an electrical
charge in the quantum field
and feelings produce a magnetic charge
in the quantum field thoughts wait
thoughts produce a what an electrical
charge okay and feelings produce a
magnetic charge and how you think and
how you feel
broadcast an electromagnetic signature
that influences every single atom in
your life the thought sends the signal
out now think about this and the feeling
draws the event back so you could have
the intent that you want wealth you want
health you want success that's your
intent that's your thought but if you're
waiting for the experience to happen to
feel it then you're not
drawing the experience to you because
you're not feeling the emotion right so
then
teaching people once again how to
balance their thoughts and feelings
because you can you can enter that cycle
either place sometimes we do a
meditation
we start opening our heart we start
elevating the body's energy and then
those emotions can drive certain
thoughts of your future other times you
open your awareness you create brain
coherence you have the vision of your
future you begin to emotionally
experience it
however you want to jump on that cycle
and then sustain it because the longer
you're conscious of that energy
the more you're drawing your future to
you so then most people spend their
lives right
they we live in this realm called
space-time three-dimensional reality and
you move your body through space in
three-dimensional reality it takes time
yeah so everything all your goals all
your dreams all your visions you're
going to have to get your body up and
drag it through space every day to pay
off that you know that home that's in
your future right right
when you create from the field instead
of from matter
when you use a vibrational match between
your energy and some potential and your
thoughts and feelings are coherent now
you are going to begin to collapse time
and space where the experience is going
to be drawn to you now now you're the
vortex to your destiny and now you don't
have to go anywhere to get it because
you're not playing by the rules of
three-dimensional reality you're playing
by the rules of energy and the quantum
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the sign says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated to get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else that jumps to 95 percent chance
from 30 something percent to 95 chance
of you following through believe nation
we need to make this happen so question
of the day your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
if the word meditation means become
familiar with right
then you know people say oh well you
shouldn't focus on the negative well
really that's 95
of who you are and you got to begin to
dismantle or denature that old
personality and that means you're going
to have to come up against the cravings
that the body has emotionally you know
like it is it's eight o'clock in the
morning and you're doing your meditation
you're normally in traffic and you want
to get angry and your body's going hey
you're off schedule so let me just find
something that's mapped in the brain
that i i'll bring up a past experience
why you can feel a little anger well
once you become aware of that
now
now the game is on right yes because now
you're working to become conscious of
that and not go unconscious again and it
takes an incredible amount of awareness
yes it takes a great amount of
consciousness and you can't have
consciousness without energy so you got
to raise your energy in order to get to
otherwise you're going to be consumed
yes you're going to return back right so
gosh so if you start becoming familiar
so conscious of those unconscious
thoughts they would never slip by your
mind unchecked by you now
that is when you really catch yourself
right and the research shows that you
can get better at this you could
actually sense the thought before it
comes so then you start firing and
wiring new thoughts you start thinking
to yourself who am i going to be when i
open my eyes well how am i going to how
am i going to make a difference in the
world today who am i going to be
how am i going to love how am i going to
give how am i going to serve how am i
going to contribute what things do i
want to really do today and the in the
act of closing your eyes and just
thinking about and rehearsing what
you're going to do
your brain doesn't know the difference
and if you get caught up in it
you begin to install the neurological
hardware in your brain to look like
you've already done it
now the brain's no longer a record of
the past now it's a map to the future
you are priming your brain and if you
keep doing it yes the hardware will
become a software program you know what
that means you just might start acting
like a happy person well there's no
surprise there you install the circuits
stress hormones arouse the body so you
have your attention on your body stress
hormones alert the brain so you're aware
of everything in your environment like
an octopus with tentacles in all
different directions you got to control
and predict everything in your life
and if you're living by the hormones of
stress you're always investing your
attention and energy into the known
future based on the past so you're on
you're on a you're in a line of time
here in a timeline so then let's think
about it
how you gonna make thought more real
than anything else are you gonna create
from thought well let's close our eyes
let's disconnect from the environment
right less sensory information coming
into the brain less distraction as you
said let's play some soft music in the
background let's stick some ear plugs in
our whatever you want to do diminish
sensory but now you're sitting down
you're not eating
you're not tasting you're not smelling
you're not feeling
so there's more less less sensory input
coming to your body so then now your
brain waves begin to change they start
slowing down and you move from this beta
brainwave pattern where
you're aware that you have a body in
space and time or your attention is on
the outer world or your senses are
giving you information less sensory
information now your inner world starts
becoming more real than the outer world
and you're not the voice in your head
that's always talking to you as your
brain waves change you start seeing
images and pictures and symbols unless
in that vocalization that
subvocalization so your brain waves
start changing the alpha you're going to
start creating start dreaming pretending
right
so then
if you say to your body
you're going to sit down for an hour and
i know you're on a program because you
wake up every morning and do the exact
same thing and now i'm going to make you
sit just like i said to an animal you
sit
you stay and your body's going to say
i'm going to die my bladder is going to
explode i need a coffee i got a lot of
emails to do that's the program
and you say to your body
today we do battle today this is it and
you sit through that and you make your
way even though your body's trying to
get up and you keep settling it back
down
i'm telling you when you start your day
that day you will be more kind
more loving less judgmental more patient
more present because you're mastering
the present moment that means you're not
in the predictable future you're not in
the familiar past you're mastering time
and so then if where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
and all of your attention is in the
present moment
you've got a lot of energy to do amazing
things and you know when someone's
present with you in your life because
they're paying attention to you yeah and
you know when they're not present
because they're not paying attention to
you so so the act of getting more
present means you're putting a lot of
energy in the present moment and you're
taking your power back from all these
things and people in your life so
we teach people this
as they start breaking through and they
start being able to unfold into this
field as an awareness
and they're not putting their attention
on their boss or their ex or their wife
or their kids or their cell phone or
their whatsapp or their facebook
they're they're they're they're not
thinking at all what's the impact that
you want to have on the world uh
i think that
the end game for me
is to empower people
to such a degree that they realize that
they need less things outside of them to
make them happy
less things outside of them to regulate
their moods and their behaviors and that
they begin to use the kind of the power
that we all have access to and and to
really uh and to change the world to
make a difference so that
there's more peace there's more
wholeness there's more connection
that we support and love each other we
serve better
and and i think that we have to start
for the most part if everybody's working
on themselves
and and
trying doing their best to present the
greatest ideal of themselves to the
world
i think the world will be a better place
and so
that's my passion and i'm witnessing it
happening now
more than i ever thought i would if you
think about this your senses plug you
into your external environment
everything you're seeing or smelling or
tasting or feeling or hearing all of
your five senses are affecting your
brain
so if you're waking up in the morning
and you're going through the same
routine behaviors as you did the day
before
and you're not in the process of being
defined by a vision of the future
then you're for the most part left with
the old hardware in your brain from the
past as a matter of fact your brain is
organized to reflect everything you know
from the past
so as people wake up and they begin to
pay attention to their body they start
to look around in their environment they
start to do typical things
it's the external environment that's
turning on different circuits in their
brain causing them to think equal to
their environment and if you have the
idea that your thoughts have something
to do with your destiny as long as
you're thinking equal to your
environment you keep creating the same
reality over and over again
so to change is to think greater than
your environment to think greater than
the circumstances in your world to think
greater than the conditions in your life
and i think every great person in
history understood this they were
defined by a vision that was much bigger
than that we have people that have been
abused we have people that have been
traumatized that have been um assaulted
we have people that have had very very
difficult difficult pasts and have you
ever heard me say to to
revisit the event have you ever heard me
say that
never do we need to revisit the event
because once you do you open the box
but what we want to do is overcome the
emotion because that's just what's
lasting from the event living in guilt
or grief or shame or unworthiness
someone tell me they lost a loved one
the other day and i said well okay how
long have you been grieving oh about a
year
really okay well suppose it was you that
left and you were looking at the person
you loved moping around for a year what
would you say to them after a year if
you truly love them
get over it and have a happy life i'm
doing great
you should make yourself happy you
really love me
live a happy life that would be the
greatest testament of love for each
other
because if you're suffering then i ah
you know you're making this hard on me
so then we always have to update our
versions
about reality because it's the only way
that we adapt
don't believe everything you've read or
heard
it just may not be the truth
there's always a greater truth that you
and i can begin to investigate
surely someone in eternity has had
similar problems you and i and have
gotten beyond it yes or no
so study that person
you want to be wealthy
study wealthy people
don't just have some panacea that you're
just going to get wealthy
read about wealthy people and find out
that they lost everything and failed
miserably 20 50 times
but what they had as a
characteristic a quality in their
personality is they were persistent and
they kept changing and they kept
forgiving and letting go of the past and
kept going and sooner or later they ran
into it and when they had all the money
they wanted it was never about the money
it was just about that they could prove
to themselves that they can do it
and you and i are no different than that
but if you can't create a future
because of some emotion that keeps you
in the past you're going to have to
square off with that emotion and when
you sit down and your body has all those
physical sensations and it's getting
vigilant and it wants to get up and it
wants to move and and you're just going
wow
and you're settling it down and you're
working with it
you gotta agree with me that something
greater in you
is climbing out of that body something
greater in you is awakening
and when you're able to overcome those
emotions truly break the addiction
don't you know that you'll return back
to your life and face the person that
betrayed you
and you will see a part of yourself that
you used to be that you no longer are
and you're not gonna have anything else
but love for them in fact you're gonna
have compassion for them because you're
going to realize how stuck they are and
you're liberated and free unconsciously
you're subconsciously asking them to
mimic your behavior and they look at you
and they follow your actions
and so when you all of a sudden
demonstrate greatness in your life and i
don't care if it's just letting somebody
ahead of you in traffic or helping
someone up or picking up a piece of
litter or garbage and people witness
that they're more prone to do the same
and so we begin to change the world i
believe by changing ourselves
[Music]
i i gotta
thank my dos amigos because their
answers are quite wonderful
if i just add something small to it i'd
just like to add this fact that
time is perhaps one of the most
important commodities in our life
and when you start losing time doing
things that you don't want to do
you start cutting your life short
so there's times that we do things
because it's habit because it's protocol
that's the way it's always done
and there are times where you can say
no thank you i really have you know i
have something going i have something
doing whatever it is to
extract yourself from a commitment to
free up your life to give you that extra
time for your personal life because this
is our personal opportunity
to experience heaven on earth and if
you're going to give away all your time
you have nothing left
so i i could you know i just went back
when we were talking about it the first
time i did that because i was thinking
about uh the whole concept of energy and
life and all that kind of stuff and i
realized god you know i just want some
more time and one of my fellow uh
faculty members came into my office and
said bruce don't forget there's a
faculty party on friday night
and i thought i said oh crap
they're the most boring waste of time
things i've ever done in my life and i
just sat there in that one moment just
having thought about that i said oh geez
i'm so sorry i have some important work
i have to do and i won't be able to
attend
and he said oh okay and walked out and
all of a sudden i said oh oh my god i
got friday night it's all for me
so i really want you to understand we we
do things by habit uh uh and just
programming and yet you are a free agent
and when you really feel that it's not
in your interest to do something you
have the right and the opportunity to
disconnect
recover your life and use it the way you
want to use it friday night is not for
faculty meetings there was another thing
that you said that i thought was really
powerful about how insights themselves
are essentially inert they don't do
anything
what what then do we do with an insight
how do we take a breakthrough moment and
make sure that it's not just a
breakthrough moment like i guarantee
people watching right now are having
like 100 aha moments
for sure that was definitely the case
for me as i was researching you and when
you said that i was like and that's the
danger that you have the aha and then
nothing yeah yeah and that's it's a it
is a danger because then people will
will shrink back into mediocracy and
they'll use the insight to excuse them
from taking a leap
they'll say yeah you know i have a
chemical imbalance in my brain my father
was
really overbearing he was a
perfectionist that's why i am the way i
am you know people they come up with
stuff
to to excuse themselves the insight is
actually giving them permission to stay
limited and it's it's
an amazing idea because
they'll say to you
that they really want to get over their
anxiety
but let's okay let's take your
ex-husband let's put him in a straight
jacket let's duct tape him and shoot him
to the moon now what i mean what are you
going to do now you still
have to make those changes
and so the person's enemy dies or
shifts in their life
and that person's gone they'll find
another person to hate this is just how
we function as human beings we just
slide another uh reason to feel those
emotions so
i think i think when people start to
understand this you know i think
knowledge is power we are living in such
an amazing time right now i mean if you
are not being challenged in some way in
your life you're not alive
and all of this is an initiation
and i don't believe that you have to go
to any school of ancient wisdom perched
in the himalayas
or for information or training any
longer if you see your life
as the school as the initiation then you
can no longer be a victim to your life
you're going to have to meet the
challenges in your life from a greater
level of mind greater than the mind that
created it
and so
there have been plenty of peer-reviewed
articles on the power of peace gathering
projects
lower crime that lower trauma incidences
of
death and
economic growth it's all related to
what's happening right now for us and
it's not enough though for us to just
focus on peace
and expect the world to change because
in the peace gathering projects when the
event was over
a lot of the crime and violence returned
back to its ceiling level again
it's more important for us
not only to embody that peace and feel
it but then to demonstrate it
and when we begin to demonstrate it
i think we give people permission to do
the same
that means that we can't be preaching
peace and then be stuck in traffic and
you know flipping people off or
you know or arguing with your co-worker
you don't get to stand up for peace if
you have conflict in your life
so when we start i believe start
that self-contemplative process of
looking within and instead of judging
someone or something look to see if
there's an aspect of ourselves within
that person or when that situation that
we may need to change and if we're all
doing that at the same time something
greater greater consciousness is going
to emerge
and so i believe that it should never be
about a person
it should be about principles
when we stand up for principles that
creates community because you could be
one belief or another belief but if
you're sharing the same principles with
your joy and freedom and cooperation and
connection that's what builds
communities
so then
everything in our world right now is
reminding us of separation whether it's
war whether it's violence whether it's
political deceit whether it's prejudice
all of those things cause us to live by
those stress hormones and when we're
living in that state of survival we're
not trusting and we become more selfish
so then
starting our day asking ourselves what
would be the greatest expression of
myself i'd like to present to the world
and then making the choice to not get up
until we are that person
i think that begins to demonstrate
greatness
and when there is adversity and when
there are challenges in our life the
question of course becomes how do we
become supernatural
and that means we're going to have to do
what feels unnatural at first when
everybody else is in poverty and lack
that's the time to give
when everybody else is in fear and
vigilance that's the time to show
courage when people are angry and hating
and prejudice that's the time to show
compassion
people are competing to rush to get to
the top that's the time to change your
energy and draw the experience to you
and if you keep doing what's unnatural
over and over again sooner or later
you're going to become supernatural as i
said 70 of the time people live in
stress and living in stress is living in
survival now
all organisms in nature can tolerate
short-term stress you know a deer gets
chased
by a pack of coyotes when it outruns the
coyotes it goes back to grazing and the
event is over and the definition of
stress is when your brain and body are
knocked out of balance out of
homeostasis the stress response is what
the body innately does to return itself
back to order so you're driving down the
road
someone cuts you off you jam on the
brakes you may you give them the finger
and then you settle back down and the
event is over and boom now everything's
back back to normal
but what if it's not a predator that's
waiting for you
outside the cave but what if it's your
co-worker
sitting right next to you and all day
long you're turning on those chemicals
because they're pushing all your
emotional buttons
when you turn on the stress response
and you can't turn it off
now you're headed for disease because no
organism in nature can live in emergency
mode for that extended period of time
it's a scientific fact
that the hormones of stress down
regulate genes and create disease
long-term effects
human beings because of the size of the
neocortex we can turn on the stress
response just by thought alone we can
think about our problems and turn on
those chemicals
that means then
our thoughts
could make us sick
so if it's possible that our thoughts
could make us sick is it possible then
our thoughts can make us well the answer
is absolutely yes
so then what are the emotions that are
connected to survival let's name them
anger aggression hostility
hatred competition fear anxiety worry
pain suffering guilt shame unworthiness
envy jealousy those are all
created by the hormones of stress and
and psychology calls them normal human
states of consciousness i call those
altered states of consciousness
so then we tend to remember those
traumatic events more because in
survival you better be ready if it
happens again that's and and the
survival gene is switched on you could
have 10 really great things that happen
to you in your day many years ago after
the dna helix was discovered by watson
and crick
they said the blueprints of life you
know all diseases are created from genes
it turns out less than five percent more
like one percent of people on the planet
are born with a genetic condition like
type 1 diabetes or tay sachs disease or
sickle cell anemia the other 95 to 99
percent are created by lifestyle and by
choices you can take two identical twins
exact same genome one dies at 51. the
other one dies at 85.
same gene different environment
so
all of a sudden they said we lied
that was wrong it's not genes that
create disease it's the environment that
signals the gene that creates disease
well okay
but that's not the whole truth too
because you could have two people
working side by side in the same factory
one gets cancer after being exposed to a
carcinogenic for 25 years both working
for 25 years the other one has no cancer
at all
so there must be some internal order
that would cause one person to not get
it while another one does
so
is it possible then if the environment
signals the gene and it does and the end
product of an experience in the
environment is called an emotion
can you signal the gene ahead of the
environment by embracing an elevated
emotion
we've done the research on this where we
measured
7500 different gene expressions in a
group of people
that came to an advanced event for four
days
and we had them doing a seated
meditation a walking meditation a laying
down meditation a standing meditation
and at the end of four days just four
days
the common eight genes that were up
regulated two genes to suppress cancer
cells and tumor growth
two genes for neurogenesis the growth of
new neurons in response to novel
experiences and learning the gene that
signals stem cells to go to damaged
areas and repair them the gene for
oxidative stress was upregulated we
started seeing all these genes that are
very very healthy to cause the body to
flourish imagine if people were doing
that for three months we also measured
telomeres the little
shoe strings on the end of dna that tell
us our biological age we asked people
to do the work meditation five out of
seven days for 60 days
measure their telomeres that determine
their biological age 60 days later
74
of the people lengthen their telomeres
forty percent significant change twenty
percent a very remarkable change that
means that they got a little bit of
their life back in order for us to truly
change we have to get beyond ourselves
and that is
one of the arts of transformation
and
with the moment we are completely in the
present moment we cannot be running a
program
it turns out coincidentally
when we're truly in the present moment
all possibilities in the quantum field
exist in the eternal now
so when we're truly present and we take
our attention off our body off of people
in our lives off of things off of places
and even time
that's the moment as i said today we
become pure consciousness that's the
moment now we are no longer playing by
the laws of newtonian physics that's the
moment we no longer have our attention
invested in this three-dimensional
reality and where we place our attention
is where we place our energy
so then the moment we become nobody no
one no thing nowhere and no time that's
the moment we get beyond ourselves
it is that act of being in the present
moment that allows us to see new
possibilities that we could never see
from the place where we are stuck in our
own programs and personality
the act of doing that as bruce said is a
skill and it requires feedback and
feedback happens in a couple ways one
way you get feedback is to begin to
measure the changes you see in your life
another way is that you feel differently
another way is that the voice in your
head goes away that's telling you can
it's too hard you'll never change
this process if it was easy
everybody would be doing it
and yet we are piercing a veil
where people are waking up and they're
beginning to take their power back
we already innately know how to do this
all we have to do is keep practicing
until we start seeing those wonderful
wonderful feedback mechanisms happening
in our life the moment you start seeing
those changes taking place in your life
you are going to pay attention to what
you did to cause it and the moment you
pay attention to the cause of that
action you're no longer thinking that
it's something out there that did it
you're beginning to realize it's what
you did inside of you to produce it
that's when we begin to take our power
back the hardest part about change is
not making the same choice as you did
the day before
and the moment you decide to no longer
think the same way
make the same choice
act the same way
create the same experience or live by
the same emotion it's going to feel
uncomfortable
it's going to feel unfamiliar there is
going to be a certain amount of
uncertainty and unpredictability
and the moment you feel uncomfortable
you just stepped into the river of
change
now most people the moment they feel
uncomfortable they return back to the
familiar state of the mind and body they
start thinking the same way acting the
same way feeling the same way and they
say this feels right
no in fact that feels familiar
now going from the old self to the new
self
is the neurological
is the chemical is the biological is the
hormonal and even genetic death of the
old self
that void
that place of uncertainty that unknown
is the perfect place to create him and
if you and i can become comfortable in
that unknown and begin to decide who we
do want to be
in other words many people say when
they're in that unknown i can't predict
my future this doesn't feel right
well the best way to predict your future
is to create it not in the known but in
the unknown
so what if you said now
what thoughts do i want to fire and wire
in my brain
what behaviors do i want to demonstrate
and if you were to close your eyes and
begin to think about how you were going
to act
the mere act of mentally rehearsing who
you're going to be
begins to install the neurological
circuits in your brain
to look like the experience has already
occurred now what that means is the
brain is primed in its circuitry to no
longer be living in the past
but now living in the future when i'm
going through change in my life or i
have a specific outcome that i want to
create i love to get up early in the
morning that's my time i'm a 4 30 in the
morning guy because that's my time the
rest of the day i'm serving but
i love getting up early and changing and
working and having some time to myself
and i believe that when i invest in
myself i invest in my future and that
time in my in my morning nobody bothers
me because that's my time
and because of brain waves and brain
chemistry
the door between the conscious mind and
the subconscious mind is more open
and so if i get up early and i'm kind of
between theta and alpha i don't have to
work as hard i'm not thinking i just
kind of relax into the moment
in the evening i always ask myself how
did i do
how was one lifetime in one day where
did i fall from grace what happened and
so
then when i look at seeing how i reacted
to someone or something or i made the
choice that i could have made a better
choice i naturally and we all do this
begin to think well if the same
situation happened again how would i do
it differently
and that's the act of beginning to come
up with a new plan
the act of rehearsing it in your mind
begins to install the circuits in your
brain priming your brain so that when
the next experience happens you could
modify your behavior to do a better job
in life that's called plasticity
so
it doesn't matter for me what meditation
i do any longer i like to just get up in
a new state of being i have people say
to me hey um
i miss my meditation today like i'm
supposed to go like this or something
and i say to them
eyes open our eyes closed
you know my eyes open our eyes closed
you know when you're passionate about
something you know when people can't get
up in the morning and they can't get out
of bed i'm going to tell you why
because they can predict the feeling of
everything that's going to happen in
their life and their bodies resigned to
the familiar it says oh another mundane
day but remember when you were a kid and
you were going on a field trip
what happened then
you were up and dressed and ready to go
before your parents were up you know why
because you knew something unexpected
was going to happen that's how we should
live our lives waking up with the
understanding to expect the unexpected
and something unusual should happen in
our life as a result of our efforts and
it's just those beginning moments where
it begins to happen that we begin to
prove to ourselves how powerful we
really are so take time in the morning
in the evening and the rest of the day
check in with yourself at certain times
to see if you're still in that energy
and if you're not excuse yourself for a
second raise your energy and step back
into your life if you keep doing that
over and over again
you'll become less frustrated less
impatient less judgmental it'll just
become something of the past and you'll
be someone else newtonian world is all
about the predictable it's all about
predicting a future but the quantum
model of reality is is about causing an
effect the moment you start feeling
abundant and worthy you are generating
wealth the moment you're empowered and
feel it you're beginning to step towards
your success the moment you start
feeling whole
your healing begins and when you love
yourself and you love all of life you'll
create an equal and now you're causing
an effect
and i think that's the
difference between living as a victim
in your world saying i am this way
because of this person or that thing or
this experience they made me think and
feel this way
when you switch that around you become a
creator of your world and you start
saying my thinking and my feeling is
changing an outcome in my life and now
that's a whole different game and we
start believing more that we're creators
of reality how do we then go from that
like mechanistically
to begin this visualization process of
something that's empowering it's me in a
different state it's my future self is
it meditation is it
what does that look like if you're not
being defined by a vision of the future
then you're left with the old memories
of the past and you will be predictable
in your life
and if you wake up in the morning and
you're not being defined by a vision in
the future as you see the same people
and you go to the same places and you do
the exact same thing at the exact same
time
it's no longer that your personality is
creating your personal reality now your
personal reality is affecting or
creating your personality your
environment is really controlling how
you think and feel unconsciously because
every person everything every place
every experience has a neurological
network in your brain
every experience that you have with
every person produces an emotion so some
people will use their boss to reaffirm
their addiction to judgment they'll use
their enemy to reaffirm their addiction
to hatred they'll use their friends to
reaffirm their addiction to suffering so
now they need the outer world to feel
something
so
to change then
is to be greater than your environment
to be greater than the conditions in
your world and the environment is that
seductive
so then
why is meditation the tool well
let's sit down let's close our eyes
let's disconnect
from your outer environment so if you're
seeing less things there's less
stimulation going to your brain if
you're playing soft music or you have
ear plugs in less sensory information
coming to your brain so you're
disconnecting from your environment if
you can sit your body down
and tell it to stay like an animal stay
right here i'm going to feed you when
we're done you can get up and check your
emails you can do all your texts but
right now you're going to sit there and
obey me
so then
when you do that properly and you're not
eating anything or smelling anything or
tasting anything you're not up
experiencing and feeling anything
you would have to agree with me that
you're being defined by a thought right
so when the body wants to go back to its
emotional past
and you become aware that your attention
is on that emotion and where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy
you're siphoning your energy out of the
present moment into the past and you
become aware of that
and you settle your body back down in
the present moment because it's saying
well it's 8 o'clock you normally get
upset because you're in traffic around
this time and here you are sitting and
we're used to feeling anger and you're
off schedule oh it's 11 o'clock and
usually check your emails and judge
everybody well the body's looking for
that that predictable chemical state
every time you become aware that you're
doing that and your body is craving
those emotions and you settle it back
down into the present moment you're
telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind and now your will
is getting greater than the program and
if you keep doing this over and over
again over and over again over and over
again just like training a stallion
or a dog it's just gonna say
i'm gonna sit
and the moment that happens when the
body is no longer the mind when it
finally surrenders
there's a liberation of energy
we go from particle to wave from matter
to energy and we free ourselves from the
chains of those emotions that keep us in
the in the familiar past and we've seen
this thousands of times in fact we can
actually predict it now on a brain scan
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some event in your life be it a betrayal
or a trauma or whatever yes the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
you pay attention to the cause outside
of you so the brain takes a snapshot
it freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called a memory
so we create long-term memories from
strong emotional events okay so is that
true i just want to understand the maybe
the larger the event in terms of its
emotion to you the stronger of a hold it
has over you yeah well the more it's
embossed in your biology so some certain
people have a strong experience in their
life
and it catches all of the brain's
attention so now they think
neurologically within the circuits of
the past experience and they feel
chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event
and you keep that refractory period of
chemicals going on for extended periods
of time so that the event produces a
chemical change and the body needs to
return back to homeostasis or balance
but if it can't then the elongation of
that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called the mood so you say ed what's
wrong with you i'm in a mood why are you
in a mood well this thing happened to me
five days ago and i'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry i don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago i'm
having one long emotional reaction i'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves
by living in the past and so then you
say to them well tell me the story now
the latest research on memory says that
50
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so we make stuff up about
the past in other words people are
reliving a life that they didn't even
have wow just to reaffirm that they
can't change right wow
so then what's the significance of this
where you place your attention is where
you place your energy period yes so then
the stronger the emotion that you have
to some problem or condition or person
in your life the more you're paying
attention to them so they captured your
attention so you're giving your power
away
to that person right because they're
capturing your attention so then there's
an energetic connection to every person
everything everything in your past
present reality has your energy
connected to it so now
this is the significance when a person
really decides to be defined by a vision
of the future instead of the memory of
the past the hardest part about it is
all of a sudden becoming conscious and
not making the same unconscious choice
so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lowered the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back three
types of stress physical chemical and
emotional physical stress trauma
accidents injuries false
chemical stress toxins pollutants heavy
metals blood sugar levels viruses
bacterias mold and then there's
emotional stress which has everything to
do with raising kids and and second
mortgages and single parenting and time
and
and all of those different elements
knock the brain and body out of balance
and the emotional component has always
been the challenging one for most people
because you could be in a constant state
of fear if you're sitting down and you
start thinking about
some future worst case scenario that
you're conjuring up in your mind
and you begin to feel the emotion of
that event
your body doesn't know the difference
between the event that's taking place in
your world our world and what you're
creating by emotion or thought alone
so most people then
they're they're constantly reaffirming
their emotional states so when it comes
time
to give up that emotion
they can say i really want to do it but
really the body is stronger than the
mind because it's been conditioned that
way so
the servant now has become the master
and the person all of a sudden once they
step into that unknown they'd rather
feel guilt in suffering because at least
they can predict it being the unknown
is a scary place for most people because
the unknown is uncertain people say to
me well i can't predict my future
i'm in the unknown and i always say the
best way to predict your future is to
create created not from the known but
from the unknown what thoughts do you
want to fire and wire in your brain
what behaviors do you want to
demonstrate in one day the act of
rehearsing them mentally closing your
eyes and rehearsing the action they're
rehearsing the reaction of what you want
or
the action of what you want by closing
your eyes and mentally rehearsing some
action
if you're truly present the brain does
not know the difference between what
you're imaging and what you're
experiencing in 3d world so then you
begin to install the neurological
hardware in your brain to look like the
event has already occurred now your
brain is no longer a record of the past
now it's a map to the future and if you
keep doing it priming it that way
the hardware becomes a software program
and who knows you just may start acting
like a happy person i'm not the type of
guy who sits in my house meditating 24
hours a day and expect things to come to
me i'm a pragmatist
i'm a practical person i'm going to take
value and information i'm going to apply
it and see if i can gain more value from
it so
the message is not to sit and meditate
and just receive universal love and do
nothing else
because my message is to not disengage
in life but to fully engage in life
that's my message when they have a
thought they just think that that's the
truth and i think one of my greatest
realizations in my own journey was
just because you have a thought doesn't
necessarily mean it's true
so if you think 60 to 70 000 thoughts in
one day and we do and 90 of those
thoughts are the same thoughts as the
day before and you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny your life's not going to change
very much because the same thought leads
to the same choice the same choice leads
to the same behavior the same behavior
creates the same experience and the same
experience produces the same emotion
and so then
the act of becoming conscious of this
process to
to begin to become more aware
of how you think how you act and how you
feel it's called metacognition and so
then
why is that important because the more
conscious
you become of those unconscious states
of mind and body
the less likely you're going to go
unconscious during the day and that
thought
is not going to slip by your awareness
unchecked
because you're
it means to know thyself and the word
meditation means to become familiar with
so as you become familiar with the
thoughts the behaviors and the emotions
of the old self you're retiring that old
self as you fire and wire new thoughts
and condition the body into a new
emotional state if you do that enough
times it'll begin to become familiar to
you so
it's so important
just like a garden if you're planting a
garden you got to get rid of the weeds
you got to take the plants from the past
year and you've got to pull them out the
rocks that sift to the top that are like
our emotional blocks they have to be
removed the soil has to be tenderized
and broken down we have to we have to
make room to plant a new garden so
primarily we learn the most about
ourselves and others when we're
uncomfortable because the moment you
move into that uncomfortable state
normally a program jumps in when that
program jumps in it's because the person
doesn't want to be in the present moment
and engage it consciously so when you
teach people how to do that with a
meditative process
it turns out that when they're in their
life
they're less likely to emotionally react
they're less likely to be so rigid and
believe the thoughts they were thinking
they're more aware of when they go
unconscious back into a habit and that
is what starts the process of change
and so we have to unlearn before we
relearn we have to break the habit of
the old self before we reinvent the new
self we have to prune synaptic
connections and sprout new connections
we have to un-fire and unwire and
re-fire and rewire we have to
un-memorize emotions that are stored in
the body then recondition the body to a
new mind into a new motion like
deprogram and reprogram that's the act
and it's a two-step process think of
your autonomic nervous system
as the automatic nervous system and i've
been saying for years that autonomic is
synonymous with automatic and it's that
part of our
systems a part of our nervous system
that functions behind the scenes of our
awareness and it regulates body
temperature and and hormones and blood
supply and blood sugar levels uh in it
and it happens without any uh
of our conscious mind
so
in the autonomic nervous system there
are two branches so one is the
sympathetic nervous system
and its job is for protection uh from
threats and dangers in our outer
environment and think of the sympathetic
nervous system as the gas pedal and when
there's a danger to the gross anatomy of
the body
by something in our outer world that we
can perceive with our senses
this system is switched on automatically
and once it turns on
there's a host of physiological
functions
that begin to happen automatically
and when that occurs we're mobilizing
all of the body's energy all of the
body's resources
for that threat or that danger to deal
with it and and when it's switched on uh
we don't go half in we go all the way in
because we have to make sure that the
body is going to survive
survive in a threat or a danger in the
outer environment and and when there's a
release of all those adrenal hormones
we're tapping the body's resources
and we're mobilizing all of its energy
and pupils dilate salivary juices shut
off respiratory rate increases heart
rate increases uh blood is sent to the
extremities glucose is mobilized the
immune system dials up and then it dials
down and all of these systems switching
on and and turning on is to be able to
allow the body to adapt to some threat
in the outer world and
that is the gas pedal and the
sympathetic nervous system or the
fight-or-flight nervous system
causes us to really do just a few things
to run
from the danger
to fight
and stay
or to freeze and hide
and those are the primary choices that
we have created in evolution
and so when the sympathetic nervous
system is switched on
and we as we've been saying for very
long uh for a very long time
uh
the short-term effect of the hormones of
stress uh the body can adapt and return
back to balance and it switches on
the other nervous system that branch of
the autonomic nervous system called the
parasympathetic nervous system
and think of that nervous system as the
break
or the clutch
this is where the body conserves energy
this is where utilizes nutrients and and
transports chemicals to cells and
metabolism goes up and and this is a
time for growth this is a time for
repair this is a time for restoration
and there's a delicate balance between
the sympathetic nervous system and the
parasympathetic nervous system
and so then when you're feeling
a constant fear
when you're feeling constant anger or
aggression when you're feeling constant
pain and suffering and you're living by
the hormones of stress
what was once very adaptive is now very
maladaptive because if stress is
knocking your brain and body out of
balance and the stress response is what
the body does to return it back to order
if we're living in constant fear then we
are tapping the body's vital resources
and there's no energy
for growth repair restoration there's no
energy for long-term building projects
crossing that river of change from the
old self to the new self there's a
neurological a biological chemical
hormonal a genetic death of the old self
but if you teach people there's
something on the other side they won't
give up on themselves they'll keep going
so there's enough evidence to encourage
people and you can't tell me you're too
old to do this work you can't tell me
you're too sick to do this work you
can't tell me you had a turbulent past
or or that you're too overweight or too
underweight or too out of shape or
you can't even tell me that you've never
meditated before in fact some of our
greatest
scans are people who just have never
meditated before that are not trying to
do anything they just follow
instructions so
our community now is beginning to
understand that it is possible
and they go all in not 50 in not 60 and
we do a week-long event we got a
thousand people or 1500 people and they
are all in and that when they start
getting beyond themselves that first day
or second day once they start getting
beyond themselves
and that magic starts to happen then i
have no idea i can't predict
what's going to happen next and it's
usually pretty pretty exciting think
about
frozen circuits
frozen circuits or hardwired circuits
the more profound the insult
to the person
that is connected to a strong emotion
the more the brain freezes circuitry
the more we think about the experience
the more we fire and wire the circuits
in our brain yes or no
and the more we remember the event the
more we produce the emotions that are
associated with it and we're
conditioning the brain and body further
into the past yes or no yes and it you
keep doing it enough times it's no
longer conscious that you're holding a
grudge
it's no longer conscious
that
you're stuck
it's now you're seeing everybody through
the lens of that experience and
everybody's a betrayer
everybody can't be trusted
everybody
is that same person you're you're
overlaying
the memory of re of your experience into
reality you're not seeing it the way it
is you're seeing that person wearing the
mask of the last person
that's the lens that we're perceiving
reality are you with me still
and so then anything in your life that
becomes remotely close to it based on
your limited perception
triggers the emotion in the network and
you're back in your past and you're
acting like you were when it happened
are you with me still
and so then the person says i'm not that
person you say oh no i know i just had
this event in my past and i'm sorry
and then it's excusable but then here it
happens again
and there's nothing wrong with this
we all do it
it's just how do we overcome it
so then
you're sitting
and doing the work
and you're you're moving energy up those
centers
you're releasing
the life force into your brain
you are blessing those centers and
taking a scoop and moving it all the way
up and releasing it all the way up into
the field you're opening the channel
you're unfolding as nobody no one no
thing nowhere in no time and the
identity and the personality is gone
which energy is going to move it's got
to it's going to follow the path
you're opening your heart once it gets
to your heart it's going to make its way
all the way up and when you feel love
and compassion
when you feel true true kindness and
care it's hard to hold a grudge
are you with me still yes
so then from a
quantum physics point of view
you have that person always in the back
of your mind right
you have the event and the memory
rolling around back there
because the very thing that you don't
want to have happen you're already
preparing for emotionally
are you with me still
so then from a quantum perspective you
are actually
as a creator of reality
holding yourself hostage
because of that person
and you are holding them hostage because
of that experience
and you have an energetic bond that's
connecting you to them
and you're sharing the same energy
and so then you're using each other to
reaffirm whatever that
energetic agreement is
are you with me still
so then
when you forgive someone
it's because there's been a strong
change
in your emotional state
because the emotion is what's keeping
you energetically bound to them or to
more than one person
and so then once you start
lowering the volume to that emotion and
the body starts liberating energy and
you're calling your energy back to you
because the lower the volume of the
emotion the less you're going to pay
attention to that person there comes a
moment where there's a snap
there's a release the energy is broken
and once it's broken now all of a sudden
you free yourself
and you free them
and
this has happened to me in my life
the people show up 10 years later
completely changed and so
humble and so asking for forgiveness
just because
they had transformed and and i let them
go
so then
forgiveness
from a quantum perspective and a
neurophysiological perspective is just
taking your attention off them that's
all it is
and when you start getting happy with
yourself
and you start feeling those elevated
emotions because you're striving for
that you wouldn't trade this for the
grudge you were holding because this
feels too good are you with me still now
once that heart opens up
and you start having energy in the
center and it's releasing 1300 to 1400
different chemicals that begin to
restore and regenerate the body the body
start getting a lift of energy once it
makes it's here now you're going to see
that track sending energy to the brain
the heart acts as an amplifier to boost
the brain
are you with me still
so then once the energy starts making
its way into the brain once the heart
starts to open we've measured this with
our students they have oxytocin levels
rise
once you start feeling oxytocin and you
feel more loved then you feel the grudge
so then you
think
why would i want to give this up for
that person
that's called forgiveness
you don't have to try to do it
it just is a side effect of your
personal transformation
and oxytocin then
when it's released rushes right into the
amygdala the survival center of the
brain and the research is outstanding
and the first thing it does is it fits
in the same receptor sites
as fear and it lowers the volume to fear
and anxiety it shuts the lights out for
aggression and anger and hostility and
it cools the circuits off for suffering
and pain and the only thing you can feel
is a love for life
and that's when you're free now the
practice
of forgiveness
matter to matter you can do it but it's
it takes a long time and a lot of work
and then you forgive and then you're
like i don't want to forgive him yeah
[Music]
halfway forgive him
and just never really authentic
forgiveness
do you understand
and you know there was a woman that came
to our work
and
she was raped by four men
when she was a teenager
and it was abusive
and
she had severe
severe night terrors
severe
anxiety and panic attacks she had cyclic
mood problems she had been to every
single doctor every single healer every
single alternative practitioner nothing
changed it
she came to our event
in
in
tacoma washington
and she hit that point where she became
everybody everyone everything everywhere
every time every place she became the
oneness
in the
and that frequency had a message for her
and it said
and she was an incredible bliss when
this happened
i sent four angels disguised as rapists
for this moment
and that was the end of her terrors
that was the end
of her night she couldn't have a
relationship she couldn't she could not
live with anybody she was she was
isolated
one moment the divine stepped in
and gave her the signal that was
carrying a very specific message and she
got the download not just that
not just the thought
she got the energy moved right through
her body and she saw the whole thing
and that moment
is what she was waiting for that's what
the soul was waiting for
now she's healed she's healthy she's
happy and she's on with a new life she's
born again my mother would love this
she's born again in the same life
reborn in the same way didn't pass
through a birth canal for it
she just was born again
in the same life she got a new lease in
one instant
that energy was carrying a message
and it made its way all the way into the
body and the bliss and the joy and the
gratitude and the love that she felt
and the message that was carried with
made total sense to her
she's free one instant
to me that's true forgiveness
that's the divine having its way with
you most people are waiting for their
life the change
so they can feel gratitude to feel
abundance to feel whole you know that's
the old model of cause and effect you
know so if you're living with emptiness
you're living with lack you're living
with pain
most people have been conditioned that
something out there has to take away
this emptiness or feeling inside of them
but
if you believe that you're creating your
life and you're living by lack well lack
is going to create abundance right so
so then it makes sense then that you
don't really actually
create wealth you generate wealth you
generate abundance so the moment you
start teaching your body emotionally
what that future is going to feel like
before it's made manifest well your body
is the unconscious mind believes it's
living in that future in the present
moment now
it's the scientific fact that it's the
environment that signals the gene okay
the end product from an experience in
the environment is an emotion
so when you begin to embrace an elevated
emotion you're beginning to signal the
gene ahead of the environment what's the
importance of that well genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and the function of
your body and the expression of proteins
is the expression of life so by you
creating an elevated emotion and
teaching your body what that future will
feel like before it's made manifest your
body's starting to live in that future
reality in the present moment now here's
the key
if you were able to become familiar with
gratitude become familiar with wholeness
become familiar with abundance to become
familiar with freedom and you're able to
generate those chemicals every single
day
more than likely you would be walking
around feeling like your future has
already happened then you would no
longer be looking for it to happen you
would already feel like it has happened
now what is the importance of that well
you're literally becoming somebody else
so you're leaving your lack you're
leaving your guilt you're leaving your
emptiness behind your personality
literally yet is made up of how you
think
how you act and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life
your personal reality you got to change
your personality and here we go again
you gotta start becoming conscious of
your unconscious thoughts you gotta
start noticing how you act how you speak
you gotta pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back to thought a new thought should
lead to a new choice a new choice should
lead to a new behavior a new behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth i
believe in human possibility human
potential and i think that one of our
biggest
limiting beliefs is the belief have how
limited we really are
and so my interest is to give people
the science to begin to understand how
powerful they really are and i think
that science really is the language that
does that really well and and the new
sciences like quantum physics and
neuroplasticity neuroscience
neuroendocrinology you know
psychoneuroimmunology the mind-body
connection epigenetics all of those
sciences point the finger at
possibilities so i want to create a
language for people
from a philosophical or theoretical
standpoint for them to begin to
understand what's possible but then i
want to be able to have those people
begin to wire that information in their
brain completely because learning is
making new connections right in the
brain
but remembering is maintaining and
sustaining those connections and it's so
much easier
to lose our vision than to remember it
right so then we have to begin to
hardwire the brain or install the
neurological hardware
in preparation for an experience so the
more people understand what they're
doing and why
then the how gets easier so i wanna then
set up the conditions in an environment
in a in a in a workshop where people can
begin to
apply or personalize what they learn so
that they can have an experience an
experience then further enriches the
brain but the prize of an experience is
an emotion and once you start feeling
unlimited once you start feeling
abundant once you start feeling worthy
now you're teaching your body chemically
to understand what your mind is
intellectually understood so knowledge
is for the mind and experiences for the
body and people begin to embody the
truth of that philosophy now if they can
repeat it over and over again
it'll become innate in them and become
natural second nature become easily
begin to master that philosophy so i
want people to begin to understand that
thoughts are very powerful feelings
drive our thoughts
and that they can begin to create a
better life for themselves once they
understand some of these principles 15
20 years ago
everybody wanted to stay in the
philosophical realm nobody wanted to do
anything with it but this is this is the
time in history where it's not enough to
know this is a time in history to know
how because information is so available
right i mean you don't need a doctor you
don't need a priest you don't need a
rabbi you don't need a governor you
don't need a teacher to gain information
you need an authority any longer because
of technology we have access to
information well information
creates awareness
and awareness is consciousness and you
can't have consciousness without energy
so people are beginning to wake up with
a greater level of awareness of what's
possible so
15 years ago 20 years ago 10 years ago i
walked out and there was always a little
resistance
but now people are coming because they
want to
actually experience the truth of it so
that makes my job easier because i can
just walk out and just fire away because
people are prepared they're informed
they're ready so anything that's not
consistent with that energy or that
level of awareness
those paradigms are beginning to break
down whether it's education whether it's
religion whether it's politics economics
the environment the medical model
everything's collapsing because people
are informed so
i love that idea because when people
show up and they say
well listen
i understand that i have a health
condition i understand that it's taken
me
10 years
of being unhappy 10 years of living in
stress 10 years of living in fear that's
actually begin to signal or select and
instruct the gene that creates the
disease well it may take me some time
then
to unlearn that process to break that
conditioning process so there's a
practical understanding now but
something amazing has happened i mean
we've spent
over 10 years doing very advanced
scientific studies we've done over 8 500
brain scans we've measured
so many
thousands of hearts because if you're
going to create a new future it requires
a clear intention an elevated emotion
well let's train our people how to
create really really high level brain
coherence and really really really
self-regulating heart coherence why
because if you're going to believe in
that future that you're creating with
all of your heart it better be opened
and activated and you better know how to
do that and you better understand the
science of what happens we've measured
gene regulation 7500 different gene
regulations we know you can change your
gene expression in four days we've
measured it you're not you're not doomed
by your genes you're your own genetic
engineer that
that um you can lengthen your life and
we've seen telomeres actually lengthens
60 days of meditation that you you add
days to your life you're changing your
genetic future that you can strengthen
your immune system by thought alone
that's
that's that's the evidence from the
scientific perspective and people
love the evidence because they start to
see that's possible
you're not going to find that in a
pharmaceutical commercial you're not
going to find that out there in the
world you got to really be hungry and
look for it so then that sets the stage
for the person to come and want to have
that experience there may not be so
quick to say hey i want to heal my body
right away they may say
i need to get my brain heart coherent
first and i gotta begin to put my effort
into learning how to do this like
learning any skill
[Music]
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there